that's what I love about uh the jackass
energy
I'm curious I was so curious I I don't I
don't want to know the answer I think
but like
I I I'm so curious if like when uh when
you guys first started doing it if there
were like teams like the the
Philadelphia team and the
Whatchamacallit it was absolutely and
there was a little bit of because I
remember like there it seemed like now
when I watched the first one you could
see a little tension between certain
people like when uh when I'm so bad at
names and I love these guys so much but
um uh danger Aaron and and Bam almost
got in a fist fight one time and they
had to break it up and they're like
don't get into a fist fight on the third
movie yeah yeah and so maybe that's the
one I saw and so and so I was like that
was the same day Ben broke my nose too
really and so I wonder like I was
wondering do they have were their squads
and then I was like I wonder if if there
were squads when everyone came in
for the new guys if it was a weirdness
or if it was like you guys have been
there so long you're like this is the
deal the weirdness was when uh Knoxville
and Tremaine announced to the the OG
cast that they wanted to bring in new
blood there was younger people and like
you know like none of us were starked on
that idea yeah I can imagine I can
imagine you wouldn't be
and as it played out okay we we resisted
it we we pushed back and they just
weren't having it they they said now
that's how it's gonna be so that's how
it was and uh day one on the set with
the new guys like they just were so
stoked to be there they were just like
the you know like we just felt we fell
in love with them right away so so it
all it all kind of dissipated it was
fine now speaking of the new guys and
and this is something that was uh pretty
crazy you mentioned I had poopies on my
podcast I did poopy's podcast boobies is
a real poopies podcast you know you I
listen to you talk about poopies and I I
do I I knew poopies from um
yeah so I was a fan I'm a fan I am a fan
of Jamie O'Brien's and pupus would be on
this podcast I knew poopies I knew part
of poopies and then I saw him on jackass
and I felt like I got to know more of
them then I saw them on your you maybe
you were on his podcast and no no I just
and I was like I was like oh poopies is
an interesting person and then when I
did poopy's podcast I could not stop
[ __ ] laughing he is a real he is an
authentic I told him he should get a
MacArthur grant you know they give
MacArthur grants to like like a lot of
people a lot of professional clowns will
get a MacArthur grants there's a lot of
money in being a clown but if you're a
really good clown like the guy from
Sesame Street yes I'm so glad you know
that yeah yeah best kind of he had him I
think he had a MacArthur grant I'm not
he's actually a Cirque du Soleil clown
he's better than Bill Irwin but what's a
MacArthur grant hey they give you like
150 a year to just keep pursuing what
you want to pursue 150 yeah 150 000 and
they just just go hey just keep doing
you you're so special we don't want to
break you we don't want to break we
don't want the world to break you
because what we think is your art form
maybe isn't um it's underappreciated so
we want to make sure that you can
continue thriving in making and doing
you and so and poopies is
a hundred percent that human being right
when I started my podcast with poopies
that got like one of the first thing
that just falls out of my [ __ ] mouth
I'm like so you're really dumb yeah it's
like the first thing I said and and
there was a lot of uh kind of criticism
in the comments and stuff people were
like man that really rubbed me the wrong
way Steve you know like [ __ ] you Steve
up for saying that yeah and I I deserved
that criticism I deserved that backlash
I I it was just a it was a Thoughtless
and uh shitty way to start the
conversation with you he's not dumb he's
just poopies does the world he's like I
mean I mean disrespectfully he's like
Theo Von Theo Von is is is
sees the world in his own unique way and
there are people I know Theo very well
and we work together on a number of
shows there are people that write off
Theo to maybe not being uh not being not
maybe done now but back then they right
off the over not being in the moment or
not listening or not paying attention
but man when he spoke it made the people
listening laugh hysterically Theo's so
quick so he's quick but he's but man you
know Theo says things I'm saying this
real
I think a lot of people think you know
spends a lot of time writing sometimes
he just says things Fisher that are just
that come out hysterical and it's the
way his brain actually operates you
can't change that you can't buy that his
he's
he's just being authentic artist like an
authentic artist and poopy has that
authenticity of like he was talking
about he was telling me a story I forgot
about
about setting off bottle rockets in his
ass and he goes do you want to know how
I came up with that idea and I couldn't
stop laughing because I was like I think
I got it but like I think I I'm pretty
sure I can ballpark it but sure tell me
how you came up with that idea of poops
but he's I had so much fun with him yeah
I love that guy man I love him too and
and
I shouldn't even try to defend myself
for just coming out of the gate saying
so you're dumb
but he's done
I don't think I don't think I think
possibility you know like he's he's so
lovably innocent and naive
there is a naivete to him I'm saying
that I'm saying that he said he's dumb
and I'm I'm saying that as not an insult
if that's possible yeah well I think I
think I I can get written in that in
that in that same stroke of the brush
where everyone goes I'm Bert's not a
very introspective person he's not a
very thoughtful person in like his
actions or his babies or his words I say
[ __ ] up [ __ ] and I don't think things
through but like but like yeah poopy's
uh he I mean he said something that
my assistant is 25 and uh
we were having dinner that night and
we're having a drink and he starts
giggling I go what and he goes
I said the poopies and thing I said how
old were you how do you remember beer
runs and he goes yeah [ __ ] yeah I
remember beer runs he goes as a matter
of fact I might I might say I I quit
doing them a little too late in life and
we're like how old were you were you for
your latest Beer Run he goes 27 and
we're like
27. my assistant's identity one he goes
I'm 25. like I would never do Beer Run
puppies is doing deer beer beer runs two
years after this day for me yeah I just
followed his poopies eyes He's 33 34.
yeah I was having a conversation with
Steve on the bus yeah poopy's was
sitting over there and I was like hey yo
dude and poopies wasn't even looking and
I was talking to Steve and he thought
that I was talking to him so every
question that I asked Steve you just
hear poopy's going yeah kinda he's like
oh no way
like dude I changed my number I I hit
him up like two days ago and he didn't
know like who who it was and I was like
Hey poops are you available to film on
the 26th in San Diego he's like oh hell
yeah dude who is this
dude it's enough that's an authentic
person there's no [ __ ] and there's
no pre-thought-outness of it you know
which is so original in this business is
someone who's not pre-thinking out like
I remember I remember uh uh Whitney
Cummings told me a story I won't say
names but it was another comic when he
told Cummings got her uh tit leaked like
some some guy had a picture of her tit
that she had accidentally Exposed on
Instagram and she had there was more
stuff and she was afraid he was going to
leak it to the Internet so she got in
front of it and she posted the picture
of her she was listening someone's
threatening that he's going to post this
I'm not going to let him do that I have
the problem power this is my tit I
posted on Instagram and then that day I
posted all right she posted a tit on
Instagram no she did it on Twitter or
Twitter Twitter and um and so
I then posted a picture of my balls
where I'd kind of ruptured a testicle
and and
I and no point did I see that as like in
a comic called her and he's like I was
[ __ ] brilliant is it real
and she was like is it real and he was
like yeah like what are you trying to
sell and she was like
the [ __ ] you talking about and she told
me about that and I went that's crazy
like so many people wondered like was
Joe Coy and Chelsea Handler like a real
relationship are they trying to sell
tickets there's because that's so much
of this business now obviously it was it
was a real relationship it lasted for a
year but but like so many people's
brains work that way and poopies does
not and it's so refreshing in this
[ __ ] business of like where even me
and you can get caught up in the thought
because you can work if you can find
some workarounds for things yeah you
know like [ __ ] you know I I remember
going in for surgery for my elbow and I
had to sell tickets at Red Rocks and I
went I'm gonna make this work for me and
I [ __ ] film my promo going into
surgery going under and like there are
some guys that and a lot of us that will
try to think things through that is not
boobies by the way that is such a
[ __ ] hilarious poopy story that
you're having a conversation with Steve
and he's in the front going yeah he's
like oh hell yeah dude he's like sick no
way like he had like four things that
like he would just say oh what a [ __ ]
great dude there's blocks off an entire
day to shoot and then says oh dude I got
a new number who's this dude or no you
got the number you know you know that
was a whole other story dude yeah yeah
that's uh dude it's it's crazy it's
called Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on Amazon and
type in Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and Order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're at ranked number 30 on all of
Amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on Amazon and buy
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude